l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement la parole
est à Monsieur Gérard Longuet pour le
groupe Union pour un mouvement
populaire monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues au moment de poser ma question
au nom du groupe de l'UMP je voudrais
apporter au nom du groupe de l'UMP
unanime notre soutien à votre
intervention monsieur le Président il
était bon que cela soit dit et vous
l'avez dit dans des termes que nous
soutenons ma question s'adresse à Madame
Marie sol Touren
elle aurait pu s'adresser à Monsieur le
Premier ministre Jean-Marc hraud parce
que le sujet de la famille est par
nature un sujet interministériel
elle aurait pu s'adresser plus
surprenante à Monsieur valalls tant il
est vrai que dans ce gouvernement en ce
qui concerne la politique de la famille
ce sont apparemment les fonctionnaires
de son ministère qui sont chargés
d'entretenir un dialogue inutilement
musclé et excessivement musclé avec ceux
qui sont les partisans de la famille de
toujours mais les réactions la raison de
ma question est autre elle a trait à la
déclaration du monsieur le Président de
la République François Hollande qui a
décidé d'augmenter les impôts pour
rééquilibrer le déficit de la Caisse
nationale d'allocation familiale cette
décision est surprenante d'abord parce
qu'elle est en contradiction totale avec
ce que le le président de la République
avait énoncé dans sa campagne dans sa
conférence de presse elle oublie
semble-t-il que déjà la loi de finances
2013 a pénalisé d'environ 500 millions
d'euros les familles dites les plus aisé
au titre du Coon familial et que cette
mesure nouvelle va donc aboutir pour un
million de foyers à adresser une note
supplémentaire d'environ 1500 € par an
ce n'est pas rien qu'est-ce qu'un ménage
aisé c'est simplement un ménage plus
ancien ou l'ancienneté l'expérience et
pourquoi ne pas le dire la réussite ce
n'est pas un mot grossier aboutit en
effet à payer plus d'impôts quel est
l'objectif de ccience familiale ce n'est
pas de rétablir à l'intérieur des
familles l'équilibre c'est de faire en
sorte que les familles qui ont des
enfants ne soi pas pénalisé à l'égard
des familles qui n'ont pas d'enfants
c'est la raison pour laquelle madame
Marie soltouren ma question est la
suivante au moment où s'ouvre le débat
sur les retraites allez-vous remettre en
chantier une mesure de bon sens qui est
de faire prendre en charge le supplément
pour les maères de famille qui ont é
élevé TR enfants et plus à la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse et non
pas à concurrence de 4 milillard 100
millions par la seule knaf si vous
faisiez cet effort nous pourrions
épargner les familles qui ont pris la
responsabilité d'avoir des enfants leur
épargner une taxe supplémentaire alors
que ce sont justement ces enfants qui
par leur présence assure l'équilibre du
régime vieillesse dans notre pays par
répartition merci merci la parole à
Madame Dominique bertinoti ministre
chargé de la
famille monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Sénateur si j'entends bien votre
question il est urgent surtout de ne
rien faire exactement contraire il est
urgent il est urgent de ne rien faire et
alors que nous avons hérité d'une
branche famille avec un déficit de de
plus de 2,6 milliards un déficit que
vous avez vous-même creusé donc il en va
il en va effectivement de la volonté de
pouvoir péréniser consolider défendre de
notre modèle social dont la politique
familiale est un des éléments important
et ne pas vouloir réduire les déficits
de la de la branche famille c'est
effectivement lourdement hypotéquer
l'avenir même de la qualité de la
politique familiale le la deuxième défi
auquel nous sommes confronter c'est de
lutter contre la pauvreté des familles
et il faut vous rappeler là aussi qu'un
enfant sur C est considéré comme pauvre
l'udicef a pointé avec une réalité qui
n'est pas à notre honneur que nous
sommes très mal placés en dépit des
prestations financières que nous pouvons
allouer au fait que nous avons une
situation de nos enfants pauvres tout à
fait contestable enfin si vous regardez
ce que sont les attentes de nos
concitoyens et de nos concitoyennes
c'est la volonté de développer des
services d'aide à la famille et en
particulier d'avoir une politique
volontariste en la matière pour
développer les les places d'accueil des
03 ans et contrairement à vous ne pas
diminuer par exemple de 55000 les places
de préscolarisation des enfants des 2 3
ans alors face à cela je voudrais aussi
pointer dans justement sur les bandes de
la droite que vous n'êtes pas unanime
car moi je me souviens des propos d'Al
la Jupé de Xavier Bertrand voire même de
Raymond Soubi qui dit que lorsqu'on est
en période de crise il faut
justement défendre notre système de
protection sociale en s'adressant et en
allant là vers les plus démunis pour
justement remettre en cause la question
de la périnité des allocations
familiales sur les couches les plus
aisées le choix qui a été fait par le
gouvernement et la solution la plus
juste la plus efficace qui est
effectivement de d'abaisser le seuil du
plafond du quotient familial qui
concerne moins de 12 des familles cela
signifie que 88 % des familles n'est pas
concerné et effectivement c'est une
politique juste et efficace pour la
pérennité de notre politique familiale
merci